le programme départemental d'insertion
engage des dispositifs visant à
consolider l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA vers l'activité et
l'emploi durable au sein de la SPL Eden
des bénéficiaires d'un contrat PEC sont
accompagnés et peuvent effectuer une
période de mise en situation en milieu
professionnel véritable immersion dans
l'entreprise qui représente une première
étape vers une insertion pérenne ces
immersions sont passées sur une à de
semaines et certains de nos
collaborateurs ont pu réaliser plusieurs
périodes
l'idée est d'approcher de façon très
concrète le monde de l'entreprise
rencontrer d'autres employeurs d'autres
organisations et en matière d'insertion
socio-pressionnelle c'est un très bel
outil pour se confronter à les
situations réelles découvrir de nouveaux
métiers confirmer un projet
professionnel voire finalement initier
une démarche de
recrutement c'est l'enrichissante en
fait du qu arri dans l'entreprise pe-êre
n point une idée fixe de ce qu'on veut
faire plus tard mais de l'entreprise ben
un suivi et ben là-dessus quoi qui donne
plusieurs idées pour de l'avenir
justement et franchement les
enrichissant moi ces stages émersion ça
m'a permis voilà d'apprendre de de
déclencher une passion de une passion
qui était existante mais de de
d'amplifier cette passion là de
m'investir même plus ici donner un sens
à la pépinière parce
que en fait mon mon souhait ce serait de
continuer avoir des expériences à
l'extérieur sur sur le vis du sujet tout
en continuant à peaufiner ce genre de
pépinière cette période d'immersion bah
ce que ce qu'on j'ai compris c'est que
j'ai fait très bonne impression donc ils
m'ont proposé de rejoindre un le groupe
de formation pour devenir formateur
alors que j'ai pas les diplômes
nécessaires normalement pour le faire
donc je je vais avoir ma chance par
rapport à
mon comment je vais dire ça par rapport
à ce qu'ils ont vu de moi ils m'ont
donné ma chance et si tout se passe bien
ça peut déboucher sur une embauche enfin
j'espère franchement
euh pour quelqu'un comme moi qui n'osait
pas trop aller vers les gens alors
aujourd'hui ben depuis que j'ai fait ce
cette imtimidation là ben je me sens
très très bien envers des comment dire
je me sens
plus je peux aller plus facilement vers
les gens grâce à cette cette Imation que
le patron a vu que j'avais des des
potentiels qui lui PLA beaucoup et c'est
pour ça qu' qu'il a proposé une
éventuelle contrat d'embauche CDD CDI
mais pour l'instant c'est en cours donc
voilà afin de faciliter ces immersions
ou ses formations en milieu
professionnel le département propose un
pack insertion logement un dispositif
qui facilite l'accès à un hébergement au
plus près de l'action d'insertion ou de
formation pour que la distance ou
l'éloignement ne soit pas un frein à
l'insertion le le pack insertion
logement a aidé énormément ça m'a ça m'a
permis de d'avancer tranquillement et de
de de de mimisser tranquillement dans
dans dans mes stages quoi j'ai j'ai tout
pris de A à Z quoi dans dans laquiétude
et ben j'ai pas le permis en fait ben mé
le le
pack insertion logement a été proposé et
du coup ben grâce à ça m'a pu faire mes
mes 5 jours là a entre deux ben dormi à
la E et voilà ben il m'avait pas de
problème de prendre le bus tous les
matins pour arriver là sur entre deux la
charte entre le département l'urce et la
CPME permettra de mettre en place des
passerelles vers le monde de
l'entreprise qui faciliteront le
parcours des bénéficiaires du RSA vers
un emploi durable